[Music]
hello I'm going to welcome honest
trailer commentaries this is a new
weekly show we've been doing on truTV's
Plus that we'll be doing here on screen
monkeys news or each week the crew from
honest trailers will be talking about
how we made their honest trailer because
people like to seemingly watch us talk
about it and a lot of things get cut out
that we decided to show that you get to
see here and that's what we're going to
do this time now we actually have a
really good exclusive for you guys so
we're going to get right to it and then
stay here because we're going to watch
it we'll talk about it afterwards but
this week we did memento hopefully you
watch it if you didn't go over the other
channel watch it quick but here we
wanted to give you something exclusive
incentives plan again and talk about it
which we typically do we have created
the forward version of the trailer
because if you watched it you saw we
made the call to go backwards which was
a lot of fun and we'll talk about that
but we haven't even seen this version
have you guys know just like the movie
it's not as good and is how we wrote it
too so I think they wrote it this way so
let's see the forward version of a
messer trailer and stay tuned we'll come
talk to you afterwards
from the michaelbay for people who rent
a book in their life comes the film that
kick-started the world's Christopher
Nolan obsession and made people mildly
aware of his brother you are the
directors brother this is not the first
time you've worked together correct now
there's been a fifth time we working
memento return to an era when all the
best movies lie to you until the very
end and experience a twisting story told
in Reverse where you already know what
happens but keeps you guessing as to why
what you talking about I don't know
because if you put it in chronological
order it's just a dude who makes a
really long phone call describing what's
wrong with him then tricks himself into
shooting someone
brilliant meet Leonard a single mindedly
obsessed white guy with slicked back
hair
aka your typical Christopher Nolan
protagonist
he's a short term amnesiac who can't
remember anything after his injury so
when he hit me from behind I remember
it's about the last thing that I gave
you except for the details of the
condition he developed after his injury
hmm well that's the thing I have this
condition condition
I guess I've already told you about my
condition my condition because of my
convictions I had this yeah all about
your condition Leonard he won't rest
until he gets revenge for the death of
his wife even though it seems like they
didn't have the best relationship to
begin with
can you read then again don't be prick
I'm eating it too annoying you I enjoy
it oh she's just not that into you bro
prepare to be shocked by revelations
like this guy isn't who he says he is
and he's actually manipulating Leonard
we can find this girl isn't who she says
she is and is actually manipulating
Leonard
and shockingly this guy isn't who he
says he is and is actually manipulating
Leonard hi to myself to be happy yes I
will
genius thrill as Lenny attempts to keep
his world in order in a pre smartphone
era whose's as he utilizes Polaroids pen
and paper trust me you can write this
down and of course his tattoos they're
one part case file fact six car license
nested 137 I one part to-do list and one
part lyrics from a new metal song memory
is treachery hmm I wonder which tad
reminds him to keep frosting is here
every few weeks yeah okay fine fine
so if you're a Nolan fanboy enjoy the
best movie ever made
until the Dark Knight which I guess was
the best movie ever made until inception
which according to you all was the best
movie ever made until the Dark Knight
Rises
look he's proved himself as a great
filmmaker but you fanboys rate Dark
Knight Rises / Citizen Kane Dark Knight
Rises isn't even the Citizen Kane of
Batman movies something feel right I
think some screaming starring jewelry
Carrie Ann Moses other movie CSI my
wifey dr. dangle Joey pants his pants
and dead
Ned Ryerson are C backwards movie that's
good but then a car we did at first
imagine every morning you wake up you
can't remember who you are your name is
M L poem
crowd looks overlaps the first thing I
see there is it really sort of shows our
template in our formula clearly yeah
this is sort of I feel like the behind a
curtain oh if you really wanted to go
watch them again you can sort of pick
out the formula of what the beats are
them yeah yeah because there is a little
bit of a formula to what we do it's not
so it's always the same but that right
there is a little bit of a story
yesterday introductory section obviously
that section I think that just the
general formula is we go from broadest
to narrowest yeah so if it starts
something like it's just about the movie
to the point where we're like talk about
how do they remember to bleach his hair
that's just the general formula if
you're looking write your own Australia
to start broad in general and get more
specific it's great but you said oh it's
not as good with it what's weird is I
like it's fine it plays like trailer but
I think what's fun about the backwards
version it was something different so it
changed up to formula a little bit and
that's why it seemingly feels like oh
yeah because we're telling a new joke in
that we haven't never done a format
shift like that right and usually dance
here we would asked animal dancing a
screen couldn't join us without Dunkirk
to have a crystal movie and we wanted
this that's why we did this and why we
wanted to try something we want to do an
old movie and we're like well we do the
prestige this.p we haven't done but we
decided when we can is to challenge
ourselves we decide to do a backwards
one there wasn't too much more challenge
because then we just ended up writing it
forwards and then playing it backwards
time yeah talk about that I like there
was a little build-up from us we were
like oh my gosh I gotta crash this one
we wrote it and there was and it was
played out pretty good right written was
forward and then we went back and
adjusted to because I've always put it
from day one of trailers my the fish
when I was running them back in the day
it would just be the dams I would sort
of break our segments up because the key
now shows always its trailer you got to
keep having segments and musical shifts
and things that sort of break up the
thing because of trailers do yeah once I
realized once we saw it like let's just
move reverse tube and I think we even
reverse tube and Istanbul is the reverse
thing you hear is that it sounds weird
it doesn't sound backwards it sounds
like there's no time but yeah I was fun
once we realized yeah just do each
section and it still sort of worked just
as we thought it like it does all work
either way that's cool I think the most
interesting from thing for me revisiting
this movie was more that aha moment I
think you said it was placing it in the
era that it came out in where every
movie was lying Joe and it had a big
twist at the end and it blew our minds
every time because all the gold man we
show really quick its usual suspects X
and 6 and bike club night club and
enigma others came out here after that
there was no but they all came out
within three or four years of each other
yeah and we're all of our favourite
movies at the time again the twist
became a big popular thing that late 90s
behind yeah and it's a you know there's
some no any stuff the protagonist is
definitely a nolan e protagonist not
like this visual splendor that we're now
used to with interstellar and Dunkirk
and stuff like that it's like it looks
like a good not student film but it's
low-budget forget love yeah there was
one joke didn't really sort of make it
in and I kept trying to pitch in they
fit it somewhere but uh I feel like the
movies when watching it again it really
so tight like it weren't enough so even
though it's kind of crazy we point out
it doesn't really hold up fully his
condition of things but they still sell
it and have a formula of looks like
every five six minutes he turns off and
does remember except for that ending
that ending scene is like twenty five
minutes and you remember him remembering
it out if he needs to remember and then
he's moved in so much going on there's a
lot of annoys me in him like come on you
guys were so good and did the soap clean
the tight but at the end it didn't like
they throw it all at the window so he
can keep remembering memento and then at
some point tattoo parlor wait oh yeah I
wrote that there thank God it's a really
like pretty tight follows its own rules
thing until yeah right up at the end and
then like Kenny does a big long sort of
scooby-doo bad guy monologue to just
kind of catch everybody uh happen and
explain it all yeah it's not really do
it easy Ned did he give the wife to
diabetic shock yeah and it's still a
little questionable to me they do leave
it a little bit open teddy is definitely
whether he's the killer or not he's
definitely a corrupt cop yeah it was
definitely dirty and manipulating this
guy you don't know if he has any more
involvement than that the big moment I
don't understand that frustrated me
after re-watching is they do the big
reveal and Teddy shows him the Polaroid
of himself and this is the day
got him and that why does he put on the
guys clothes the suit yeah because that
is a fighting incident for the rest of
the movie that's how she I'll give you a
mystery to solve that's why he does it
he drops the license plate down and
takes the other guys car he's just sort
of a huge dick yeah just quickly realize
now imagine condition down whatever I'll
kill somebody
yeah house that was weird to me um it's
better than I thought it would be
they're looking back yeah yeah oh yeah
big gimmick movie just looking back and
it wasn't it's actually a gimmick does
help it though it helps because you're
in his head just like him you can only
really trust what you've just seen yeah
I love that scene with Carrie and matras
like I'm gonna [ __ ] use you you know
but then depends away got a record
oh and then you watch it you just saw
already saw a new dimension I do wonder
how you know if this would come out two
years later when like the iPhone was
that well not you know at least on
violet if you had a young priest he
could have always remember largest yeah
but that would have like dates and times
and and would be a lot let's have a
password I guess you'd forget the
password for avoiding so yeah yeah it's
kinda round and I'm really happy made
now we could have a thumbprint right the
the clean slate so I like using the talk
boy the tape recorder yes your this
every time you listen this message
oh man the music in that in that clean
slate trailer so that it's a late 90s
comedy Wow sounds good yeah this movie a
lot of things I loved in 2000 do not
hold up at all anymore in memento really
does yeah it's good it shows you've got
something I liked it it definitely makes
you think and it's something different
you see it's the format did help it even
the into and you'd think that would be
really hard to do and not follow but it
does follow yeah I mean it doesn't
really focus doesn't really make sense
easy but those are open to questions I
don't think make it eat the movie less
sensical
yeah and I guess props to the Jonathan
Nolan I think that his set cliff that
terrible I'm sorry for always being
called
a Chris Nolan's brother that's got to
get annoying because you've done a lot
yeah yeah but I think this is like
really playing to his strengths because
he is good at like mind-bending logic
puzzles and stuff like that and maybe
character work isn't his strongest suit
or this kind of Elliott but this kind of
yeah it didn't need that and then yes
sometimes he can take it too far and
interstellar and in West world but I
think that this is just right now it's
off like a tight like 80 90 minutes yeah
so rare for him although I'm Kirk right
here is also limited times yeah yeah a
nice little short quick story they don't
have to be three hours long yeah I had a
final thoughts to wrap this up
props to Kevin for that our editor for
that uh Jonathan Nolan clad yet so Larry
on and when I memory Treasury does
everybody on Miller's killers are
talking about or any other metal songs
that could be done sort of like memento
mean we're yeah want you a tweet those
at us we do this like I'm in a point do
we have I don't mess no metal song I
don't think we had any cut stuff
released you have some million of scenes
and that's what we do in the show every
week we bring you some scenes extensive
then typically we start and stop the
trailer since you've already seen it but
this one we had a exclusive to show you
so we gave you the exclusive on it
uninterrupted but let's see some
uninterrupted optics or I guess all
story ultra sorry man here's Guy Pearce
on the Ted man feed up a bed up up the
Time Lord the time Anita rash oh man
micron assure snores oh Punishers the
matrix cypher Raige Joe Pardy point
aside from all those movies definitely
one of the good cop bad cop yeah we
usually cut more than that but this one
was okay we're in an insane rush to get
everything done for Comic Con static
there's no time is enough but it can be
singing a tune in no I'll here on news
never else for more stuff on the
comic-con but yeah I thought this one
turned out really well and the things I
was worried when I was going to see the
cut and then we watched I was like I
liked that a lot
yeah we like let me break down break it
a little bit change n we were really
ready to I think to be like oh we got
sell ourselves on this one and then is
good right kind of right up again yeah
tell us what you saw tell us in the
comments below what you thought and give
us your heavy metal momento titles down
there I want to see some more of those
common man forgetting something early
Creed okay change uh if that creator
stained tell me what I'm parroting and
we'll be back here every Tuesdays
usually will link these sometimes from
the Tuesday honest trailer
otherwise you'll see them live here on
Wednesdays on-screen of these news hope
you enjoy the show
we'll see you next time have a wonderful
week bye bye